we're gonna read the question out
together and as I read it I want you to
stop me whenever I should write down a
critical detail so this is question
truth okay
as I guess what just shout out what I
need to jot down a particle of mass four
kilograms do I need to write down to the
particle yeah but you'll always be a
particle or a body of no significant you
know unless it's like okay if this
resistive motion then they will tell you
what what the force of resistance is
okay fastened to a string two meters
long okay good revolves as a conical
pendulum with the mass moving in a
horizontal circle at ruiji meters per
second
how should I write that what do you
think are the most salient details out
of there the most critical yes it says
it says meters per second so that Clues
you into the poem this is not Omega that
would be radians per second this is I
like to write just so I don't confuse it
for myself the linear velocity or the
tangential velocity in secular motion
does the same thing is going to be root
G means per second okay good
have a look do I know anything else are
there any details that have been
provided that I'm missing no that's it
right now it comes to the question find
the tension in the string and its
inclination to the vertical so tension
inclination okay so that's where I'm
going to go right now go back through
all of your let's let's work out a
partner okay go back through all of your
equations all that kind of thing to fine
tension to find tension where are you
going to go what do you think is the
best thing to use okay it'll be a quick
one time so you've got sure
like so I could fill in that this is two
meters over here yeah I've got this
vertical it's not very vertical you get
the idea
there's the inverted commas Center
action it's the centre of motion um
you've got what what else do i know on
this I've got mass orgy okay it feels
yeah I know that we've lost here like
how you gonna draw that I suppose you
could do something like this
you could say something like around this
way right that's a decent repertory you
can draw a tangent if you wanted most be
fine
that's root G m/s okay is there anything
else I can put my diagram yeah I think
Pete is probably worth putting up there
okay okay so this is all fine now I've
got a diagram right I'm gonna come back
to this original question where am I
going to go tension what's an obvious
choice obvious m/l and mega squares
right this is the obvious choice good
way to go okay except I don't know what
I know what massive like that but I
don't know
angular velocity right so how am I going
to find angular velocity what do the
question is going to help me get there
okay so the angular velocity you may
recall this is defeat on duty right so
it's related to linear velocity it's
proportional to linear velocity in what
ratio do you remember
so I think the first way we wrote it was
that lead equals Omega right because
this comes from X or L changing which is
R theta so it's off by a factor of 1/2
does that make sense so therefore I can
work out what their meter is if I know
what V is and if I know what R is okay
I know what V is but I don't know what R
is question mark okay so how am I going
to work out what R is what does odd
depend on yeah okay so I need to know
this I've got an angle up here and then
I've got this guy over here but then I'm
like well I don't know what the angle is
though like that's part of the problem
okay so I want to know oh he's gone okay
so what can I use to help me yeah hmm if
I don't know the angle I do know this
side over here right to find out like
what's going on in this right angle
triangle I need to know a little bit of
extra information right for example it
might be super helpful if I knew what
this height here was okay if I knew what
the height was do I know something
became work help me work out that this
height is okay so ah I was defined by H
right I mean I could say it the other
way around
we justified by the come on and H is
what was that expression to remember
well huh okay no I think this looks a
little bit circular this these things
that depend on things right but I think
this will be enough we could we can go
from here because I can work out but
these things all fit together and some
things will cancel that and it will work
for me okay so I think this is enough
for me I'm going to start to chop my
path through this question all right
first thing we're going to do is I'm
going to start from the base where I
know lots of things okay so that better
be Mooji over here I know what this
force is so I can start to feed into
this this guy over here
okay so I can say V is equal to root G
okay but they is the derivative with
respect to time of the a clique that's L
right by in terms of all the stuff that
I'm talking about here that's I feel
okay you're Jake does that make sense so
this tells me okay
DDT
yep that's a meter how am I gonna use
this how's this gonna help me yeah I
can't now just file it away for a second
when you have a look at this guy over
here h equals G Omega squared right
look look what's going to happen here
right you see this is going to get our
relationship between H and O what
happens when I substitute is this is G
divided by l squared that's Onaga isn't
it you see what's happening games this
is really good this is G on R squared so
the G's will cancel and you're just
kidding that is that useful to me yeah
you bet it is is it super useful right
because now if I've got our then I've
got R squared and I already have this
hypotenuse to so I can use this to work
out what's going on right how am I gonna
do it said you okay so because I don't
know what R is right um you know I could
say any any trig ratio here requires two
sides to be known but I don't I've only
got one side known right so I'm gonna
have to go to Pythagoras okay so I'm
going to say what we got here a squared
plus B squared equals C squared
yeah so that means ah to the 4 plus R
squared equals 2 square yeah okay this
is a quadratic
if r-squared do you create that so if
it's a quadratic in a square and just so
I squared
tell me what's right minus B plus or
minus the square root of b squared minus
4ac yeah on two that's two solutions
they have to be because you're using the
quadratic formula but I can disregard
one of them which one and why disregard
the negative because it's not only is it
linked it's a way squared so it's good
it's super positive okay so I'm gonna
say our equals and I'm just going to
take the positive one since since R
squared is positive yeah so therefore R
itself is actually equal to the square
root of the square root of 17 take away
one on two it looks messy it doesn't
feel like it should be there right on
the top you're like I got square roots
are the square roots
but we've seen square roots under square
roots before right it kind of happens
because of like all this stuff right if
you've got things that are related by
that related to in proportion to each
other's squares then you're going to get
square roots happening all the time okay
and then the other square root came from
the quadratic formula so I guess we just
have to do with a slightly messy number